now it's very exciting the other day
this is amazing the amount of money you
guys raised there was that auction for
various charities of all the bond
paraphernalia and bond mementos the
aston martin sold for two hundred and
forty-one thousand and this is the model
there's a little that that went for
sixty one thousand pounds i mean it's
amazing the thing your watch of yours
157,000 and that day judy you were in
charge of one of the star lots were you
not
I was I was able they said would you
bang the gavel on Daniels pants
[Laughter]
and they were estimated I think between
three and five thousand pounds and I
think they went for thirty five thousand
pounds
I got forty four thousand forty four
yeah reference the Ursula Andress think
of me out of the sea what we did in the
script it happened by accident really I
mean the the blue those things came up
in there where we were filming I was I
was supposed to be swimming across you
know and I was supposed to sort of stand
up and sort of look around but the water
was a keynote slope in some places where
the water just stays at this depth for
about a mile
yes so I kind of swam like kind of
pretended we were then stood up and was
there and that's how this short happened
so it was by accident more than anything
because I mean you know I can see what
they ask you take your shirt off and
you're very generous with your body in
this new this new look insightful the
laundry bills very low your your shirt
that's a lot looser Duke you don't look
like do you not like that all the time
or do you have to get ready for these
now no III start training about I have
six months before we start shooting and
then and then and then continually but
what's lucky about it is that we plan
out the sort of shirtless scenes quite
carefully so I can sort of D carb and do
all that so we're really boring stuff
and then the rest of the time I just
even drink what I want just trying to
stay in shape
[Music]
you